hey this is preshtalwalker solve the
following equation
3x to the power of log 3 is equal to 4X
to the power of log 4.
X is a real number and we're dealing
with the real exponentiation operator
I think on from Vietnam for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so when I first approached the problem
my instinct was to take the logarithm of
both sides
I did solve for x but my answer was
incomplete and wrong I only found one
solution and in fact there are two
solutions
so this approach directly is a mistake
the reason is that the power rule of
logarithms only works when the base is a
positive real number
But first you need to check the domain
to consider the other cases
so first we need to check what happens
if x is less than zero
in that case we have a negative number
to an irrational power and that is
undefined for the real exponentiation
operator so we dismiss this case
but now what if x is equal to zero
in that case we have 0 to the power of
log 3 is equal to zero to the power of
log four which is equal to zero so X is
equal to zero is a solution and I miss
this case because I directly applied the
logarithm to both sides
but anyway we figured out that X is
equal to zero is a solution now we can
consider the case that X is greater than
zero
we can now apply the logarithm to both
sides and now we can use the power rule
for logarithms we'll bring log 3 to the
front and we'll bring log 4 to the front
so we'll do these one at a time
so if log 3 multiplied by the logarithm
of 3x and we have log 4 multiplied by
the logarithm of 4X
let's now simplify this equation
log of 3x is equal to log of 3 plus log
of x and log of 4X is equal to log of 4
plus log of x so we substitute those in
we will now distribute log 3 on the left
hand side and log 4 on the right hand
side
let's now group like terms we'll bring
all the constant terms to the left hand
side and all the terms with log X to the
right hand side
so on the right hand side we have log X
and we Factor so we have log four minus
log 3 and on the left hand side we have
the square of log 3 minus the square of
log four the left hand side is a
difference of squares so we can Factor
it as the product of their sum and their
difference
so now let's work from this equation
we'll divide both sides by log four
minus log 3.
log 3 minus log 4 is the opposite of log
4 minus log 3. so these cancel out to be
negative 1.
so we have log X is equal to the
opposite of log 3 plus log four but log
3 plus log 4 is equal to log 3 times 4
which is equal to log 12.
we're getting close
so negative log 12
will be equal to log of 12 to the
negative 1
12 to the negative 1 is equal to 1 over
12.
we now exponentiate on both sides so we
get that X is equal to 1 over 12.
so there you go for the original
equation we have two solutions X is
equal to zero and X is equal to 1 over
12. and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign